allora
giorno come sapete
però di non correre troppo vi parlerò
media quindi vuol dire che non parlano
dei poveri sicuramente parlerò dei
poveri perché in qualche modo di prova
di se ne parla molto anche se poi si fa
poco matera un però dei ricchi in
rapporto alla classe media non farò la
relazione a l'italia di cui abbiamo
parlato poco finora
vorrei partire con questa affermazione
con questa cosa che sarà scritta molto
tempo fa da un economista che forse è
stato sottovalutato ma meriti più
rilevanti di quelli che si sono stati
riconosciuti come vedete scriveva questo
economista che si chiama alesse d'oro
nel 1984 quindi 31 anni fa secondo la
saggezza convenzionale la classe media e
la colla che tiene insieme alla società
se questo è vero allora la nostra
società si sta scolando questo scrive il
toro contiene un'affermazione chiara la
classe media e considerata la colla
nella società la classe media
considerata la colla della società e
contiene una affermazione implicita che
è quella per la quale la classe media
sta in qualche modo perdendo terreno si
riferiva agli stati uniti tra loro con
questa affermazione di questo problema
della riduzione del restringimento se
volete anche della sparizione nelle
versioni più estreme della classe media
si occupano molti sono occupati i morti
il primo problema che abbiamo però di
definire la classe media e poi quello di
misurarla che cos'è la classe media
quanto reddito quanto ricchezza accomuna
che cosa rappresenta il suo benessere
come stanno andando le cose
qui ci abbiamo da considerare che il
termine classe media ha fatto il suo
ingresso nel panorama delle nozioni
utili per comprendere la stratificazione
sociale della disuguaglianza del xix
secolo quando le società erano molto
semplificate c'era semplificando la mia
volta
l'aristocrazia al top è qualcosa che si
può chiamare il proletariato alla base
arrivo questa classe chiamiamola così di
imprenditori borghesi che occupò questo
spazio enorme tra così due estremi era
abbastanza omogenea al suo interno
sufficientemente diversa dalle altre due
il problema di individuare la classe
media non si poneva le cose sono molto
più complicate
la stratificazione sociale è diventato
un fenomeno complesso e una recente
ricerca svolta in gran bretagna
consultando
era molto molto elevato di persone ha
portato alla conclusione che oggi
viviamo in un mondo con almeno sette
classi sociali dall'inizio vedete la
classe media ben estate la classe media
tecnica fino ad arrivare al precariato o
proletariato precario e che rende
estremamente difficile rispondere alla
domanda dove sta la classe media in
questa classificazione il problema è
complicato dal fatto che come risulta
bene da quella indagine le variabili in
base alle quali ci si può considerare
parte o meno della classe media sono
molteplici sono quelle di carattere
economico il reddito e la ricchezza
ci sono quelle che hanno a che fare con
il podio grado di istruzione che noi
economisti che amiamo capitale umano ma
si sono anche il tipo di professione che
viene svolto le relazioni sociali di cui
disponiamo sono una variabile che entra
nella definizione di classe e quindi
classe media e anche quello che viene
chiamato capitale culturale queste
variabili si possono combinare in modi
molto diversi nella società complesse
che noi viviamo e creano una
complicazione rilevante per poter
parlare in maniera individuata e ben
precisa di classe media questo spiega
anche perché a risultano numerose
interviste che la stragrande maggioranza
delle persone molte di più di quelle che
ragione con vette potrebbero essere
considerate classe media pensano di se
stesse di far parte della classe media
vediamo un attimo però come se la cavano
gli economisti miei colleghi tendono un
po semplificare le cose quindi la
buttano sul semplice calcoliamo soltanto
il reddito
ovviamente si tratta di una
semplificazione ma una semplificazione
non risolve tutti i problemi e che ci
restituisce anzi molti problemi in ogni
caso ci illumina un po avendo detto che
era variabile di davanti e il reddito
abbiamo risolto pochi problemi dobbiamo
poi definire in termini di reddito dove
sta la classe media e qui si confrontano
varie posizioni una che dice la classe
media e quella che percepisce un reddito
che è più alto di quello che prende il
20 per cento più povero e più basso di
quello che prende il 20 per cento più
ricco in questa idea quindi la classe
media è una popolazione definita e si
espande così le 16 a seconda che il
reddito che percepisce questa
popolazione definita vada succo vada giù
rispetto al totale una visione
alternativa è quella che dice fissiamo
dei paletti
reddito entro questi paletti c'è la
classe media oltre ci sono i poveri e
ricchio come ti vogliamo chiamare questi
paletti vengono normalmente posti il 25
per cento sotto il 25 per cento sopra
quello che è il reddito mediano cioè il
reddito che divide la distribuzione in
250 per cento e più povero di questo
reddito del 50 per cento e più ricco e
questo è un altro criterio in questo
caso quindi si fissano i paletti e si
calcola quante persone ci stanno dentro
la classe media si restringe se meno
persone stanno dentro questo intervallo
ci sono altri criteri che tendono in
maniera semplificata a fissare comunque
dei paletti a cercare di vedere quanto
la classe media e lontana dai ricchi e
vicina ai poveri
nessuno di questi criteri e
soddisfacente peraltro se noi lo
applicassimo alitalia negli ultimi venti
anni circa troveremo che la classe media
e immobile questi calcoli che vi
presento vi dicono per esempio che la
quota di popolazione che nel 1995 aveva
un reddito compreso in quell'intervallo
che vi dicevo è poco diversa da quella
che c'è nel 2012 quindi apparentemente
c'è in mobilità così come si è apparente
immobilità se usiamo il criterio di
quanto reddito percepiva il 60 per cento
intermedio
il fatto che sia immobile ovviamente non
vuol dire che questo rappresenti
correttamente il fenomeno della realtà
che questo indicatore sia immobile a
parte che dentro questa immobilità ci
possono essere segmenti che si muovono
in maniera molto diversa se ovviamente
anche il fatto che il reddito non è
indicativo dello stato di benessere di
questo segmento della popolazione ci
sono problemi collegati come è ben noto
alla maggiore variabilità dei redditi
una crescente insicurezza ci sono
problemi che venivano prima menzionati
anche da riccardo di perdita di
prestigio di alcune professioni o
addirittura di sparizione ma comunque se
usiamo misure più sofisticate di classe
media basate sul concetto di
polarizzazione arriviamo al risultato
diverso qual è il concetto di
polarizzazione e poi andare a verificare
se coloro che stanno in basso coloro che
stanno molto in alto sono più coesi e
più omogenee
e al loro interno se aumenta questo
grado di polarizzazione vuol dire che si
svuota il centro cioè vuol dire che la
classe media
perde terreno si fanno calcoli più
sofisticati sulla base di questo
indicatore e si può anche stabilire se
ognuno di noi che oggi occupa una certa
posizione nella scala dei redditi con lo
stesso reddito che a oggi facendo le
dovute proporzioni avrebbe occupato
dalla stessa posizione di ieri
oppure una posizione peggiore nella
scala dei redditi e si scopre che molti
occuperebbero una posizione peggiore
quindi questo vuole dire che abbiamo un
indicatore più sofisticato e più
credibile di arretramento di quella che
possiamo considerare in vario modo la
classe media
con questo esercizio scopriamo
chiaramente che le distanze tra quella
che si chiamiamo classe media e il top
and bottom cioè il vertice della parte
bassa sono cambiate sia allontanato il
sia cresciuta la distanza dal top e si è
ridotta la distanza dal bottom
vediamo alcuni dati alcuni li abbiamo
già visti prima
questi sono i dati di come si è evoluto
il botto di una serie di paesi non
soltanto negli stati uniti di cui
abbiamo parlato finora è troppo un per
cento di reddito cioè quanto predetto
nazionale la quota e radio nazionale che
affluisce all'un per cento più ricco dal
1980 ad oggi vede che decennio dopo
decennio
questa quota cresce praticamente ovunque
gli stati uniti e la gran bretagna sono
a destra sono addirittura esplosivi di
ampiamente in italia non se la passa
tanto male se questa è una misura di
buon successo anche i paesi scandinavi
la svezia vedete c'è un peggioramento
notevole
i due paesi che in qualche modo
contengono questo fenomeno sono la
francia e l'olanda per motivi che non vi
sto qua non vi posso dire
soffermiamoci però sull'italia e sugli
stati uniti per un istruttivo paragone
queste sono le quote appunto di reddito
che andava non per cento nel 1980 nel
2007 in italia si passa dal 6,9 al 9,9
è un aumento notevole quasi il 50 per
cento in più che va a questa categoria
di persone negli stati uniti è
enormemente di più abbiamo fatto due
calcoli per darvi un'idea di che cosa si
tratta
qui che cosa c'è il reddito medio
dell'un per cento e il reddito medio del
resto della popolazione
sono 180 e nel 2007 questi sono dati
veri cioè sono dati tratti dalle
indagini di cui disponiamo
nel 1980 degli stati uniti il reddito
medio di chi aveva faceva parte non per
cento più di quella 355mila dollari nel
1900 il 2007 era diventato più di un
milione di dollari quindi era
praticamente triplicato in italia era 94
mila euro ed è diventato 180 mila euro
che vuol dire che più o meno è
raddoppiato nel frattempo il reddito
medio lo vedete nella parte più bassa
del della tabella negli stati uniti è
passato da 43 e 57 con un incremento del
32 7 per cento in italia dal 13 al 18
con una 21 minimo del 34 fatevi i conti
di quale di quanto è aumentata in
termini assoluti la differenza tra
questo reddito medio del reddito del top
è comunque un indicatore semplice è
quello di chiedersi quanti redditi medi
si volevano per fare un reddito dell'un
per cento e si è passati in italia da
6,8 redditi medi per un reddito al top
per cento a ben 10 quindi questo video a
metà delle distanze
ovviamente in quel 99 per cento non c'è
solo la classe media si sono anche
coloro che stanno più in basso
tuttavia questo è un indicatore molto
preciso di come si sono allontanate le
distanze e facciamo qualche zoomata
dalla classe mia di naturalmente si può
anche uscire qualcuno se lo ricorda che
dalla classe media si riesce come per
attenuare la gravità del problema
per esempio se lo ricorda jordan belfort
il quale si dice sono un ex membro della
classe media cresciuto a due ragionier
in un piccolo appartamento di bayside a
queens a 26 anni viva la vendetta di
brokeraggio e ha cominciato a guadagnare
49 milioni di dollari e arrabbiato per
il fatto che il 49 a meno di 52 e quindi
non arriva nemmeno a un milione di
dollari alla settimana questo come
saprete potete immaginare tratto da the
wall street a wall street ma è
assolutamente realistica questa immagine
per i molti che per i pochi che riescono
a uscire verso lato ci sono molti che
restano i molti che regrediscono e
dobbiamo chiederci qual è il meccanismo
che produce questi effetti al di là
delle cose che sono state già dette
certamente un meccanismo è quello che
produrrà prodotta interno delle imprese
quello spostamento di reddito da tutti
gli altri ai manager questo è avvenuto è
avvenuto perché all'interno delle
imprese il potere si distribuisce
diversamente studi recenti anche del
fondo monetario quindi di organizzazioni
diciamo che non dovrebbero avere un
particolare una particolare simpatia per
la classe media dimostrano che laddove
si è indebolita per esempio il potere
dei sindacati o ha cambiato funziona il
ruolo del sindacato si è verificato uno
spostamento di reddito verso la parte
alta della distribuzione ma non voglio
parlare di questo anche perché il primo
da questo grafico che avete già visto
che ha fatto vedere riccardo quindi un
piccolo raddoppiamento di questo grafica
è l'idea è il rapporto tra quanto
guadagnano gli amministratori delegati e
quanto guadagna un lavoratore delle
imprese americane dal 65 al 2008 parlare
di un'altra cosa che voglio parlare del
settore pubblico in italia quindi un
piccolo particolare ma molto rilevante
qui troviamo dei dati che abbiamo
elaborato su un rapporto tra il guadagno
diciamo di un dirigente ricco
rappresentato carico nel senso che
guadagna un reddito elevato p 95 in
questo grafico è un di un lavoratore
della pubblica amministrazione medio p50
è uno che stava verso il basso p25
quello rosso rappresenta il rapporto tra
quanto guadagna dirigente che guadagna
di più e quello che sta più in basso è
quello azzurro invece il rapporto di
dirigente in alto è quello medio vedete
che c'è una tendenza forte e
significativa all'aggravarsi delle
sequenze in seno all'amministrazione
pubblica dove c'è una gran parte di
classe media per tante ragioni in italia
all'interno del settore pubblico con
tutte le professioni potete immaginare
un secondo punto importante è
sottovalutato ma che a mio avviso molto
rilevante è come si entra nel mercato
del lavoro e dove ci si colloca quando
si entra nel mercato del lavoro
molti si collocano direttamente nella
classe media che si godano si collocano
molto al di sotto cui abbiamo calcolato
i salari di ingres dipendi di ingresso
in tre generazioni e abbiamo visto nei
sei anni successivi all'ingresso come è
andato il loro reddito quindi sono tre
corti invito a guardare il pannello di
destra che si riferisce solo ai laureati
i più danneggiati di questo da questo
fenomeno che vi sto per dire
la linea azzurra rappresenta i redditi
d'ingresso quindi nell'anno zero e la
loro crescita per i sei anni successivi
all'ingresso per i nati negli anni 65 69
le altre due linee rappresentano gli
stessi dati per i nati nel 70 74 nel 74
come vedete la differenza è
significativa e rilevante le generazioni
successive di laureati entrano con un
salario più basso in termini assoluti e
hanno anni di carriera 56 anni in cui le
distanze rispetto come chiamarli ai loro
fratelli maggiori ai loro padri tendono
ad aumentarsi che voglio dire che se
qualcuno sulla linea azzurro molto sulla
linea azzurra erano classe media appena
entrano nel mercato del lavoro oggi
molti di questi non sono classe media in
base alla definizione che noi possiamo
dare quindi c'e un problema
rilevantissimo che colpisce soprattutto
i laureati gli stessi dati riferiti a
titoli di studio più basse danno una
differenza molto minore i figli della
classe media sono spesso laureati una
delle asset della classe media è il
titolo di studio se viene trattato in
questo modo in un epoca in cui peraltro
si parla di capitale umano come nella
più grande delle asset davvero terribile
come si dice spesso si parla tanto di
sviluppo sostenibile non si è mai fatto
un danno così rilevante all'ambiente
come adesso si parla tanto di capitale
umano e lo si tratta piuttosto male in
questa epoca
andiamo alla ricerca brevemente di
spiegazioni dove le possiamo cercare io
ho sottolineato la correlazione tra la
concentrazione al top e il peggioramento
della classe media
ma questa concentrazione troppo a cosa è
dovuta
è dovuto in primo luogo al nostro parere
alla concorrenza distorta non è il
mercato in quanto tale il mercato
funziona come noi vogliamo farlo
funzionare e quindi le ragioni per le
quali si producono redditi enormi
all'interno dei mercati è il frutto di
alcune regole che noi diamo potrei
trattenervi a lungo se avessi qualche
minuto in più su questo aspetto la
faccio un solo esempio non so le
modalità attraverso le quali vengono
consentite o non consentite terminate
barriere di accesso a determinate
professioni sono rilevanti per il
formarsi di reddito non è soltanto una
questione quindi di tecnologia non è
soltanto una questione di
globalizzazione la prova sta nel fatto
che paesi esposti agli stessi rischi di
globalizzazione e di finanziarizzazione
di cambiamento tecnologico hanno
disuguaglianze molto diverse vuol dire
che hanno regole di funzionamento dei
mercati molto diversi il secondo punto
il calendario delle imprese si è
modificata la distribuzione del potere e
quindi sono diventati più potenti coloro
che hanno redditi più alti e una
precisione moltiplicano loro posizione
la terza questione era limitata la
distribuzione che viene attuata dal
welfare state sia dal lato delle entrate
perché le imposte sono diventate meno
progressive sia dal lato della facilità
di accesso di molta classe media e la
fruizione di una serie di servizi del
web che precedentemente erano gratuiti o
liberi che adesso sono sottoposti a
prove dei mezzi a selettività che in
qualche modo danneggiano questo segmento
della popolazione
un caso estremo è stato già citato da
riccardo è quello il vincitore che
prende tutto mercati nei quali si
afferma un solo offerente che vediamo
così che riesce a coprire 80 il 90 per
cento del mercato corredi non c'entra la
tecnologia ma centra anche il modo nel
quale vengono distribuiti tra coloro che
partecipa al processo produttivo i
frutti del risultato consentito dalla
tecnologia un problema dei diritti di
proprietà potremmo dire e poi c'è un
altro aspetto lo decida va perché ti
poco fa la classe media piccoli
patrimoni a piccoli piccoli ricchezze se
il tasso di rendimento cresce con la
ricchezza le disuguaglianze le distanze
dalla classe media il top aumentano non
perché ovviamente a mente il valore
assoluto momento anche in termini
relativi è un patrimonio piccolo frutta
il 3 per cento
e frutto del 10 per cento le distanze si
allargano che cosa accadrebbe se
continuasse così si parla spesso di
crescita come soluzione dei problemi
abbiamo fatto due calcoli supponiamo
miracolosamente che l'italia prende a
crescere al tasso del 2 per cento e lo
faccio per il 18 anni quindi per un
tempo illimitato al termine di questi 18
anni
supponiamo di chiederci come si è
distribuito questo frutto della crescita
immaginando che si distribuisca come si
è distribuito in paese che ha conosciuto
l'aggressione degli anni 90 gli anni
2000 gli stati uniti un non per cento di
due terze la crescita al restante 99 per
cento un terzo della crescita
l'esito sarebbe dopo 18 anni di questa
straordinaria crescita che al 99 per
cento il resto di 99 per cento del
reddito crescerebbe soltanto di un
misero 15 per cento che per molti vuole
dire 300 euro al mese nel frattempo il
restante 1 per cento avrebbe visto
crescere il premio radio del 130 per
cento e con questi risultati si
accaparrerebbe nel nostro paese da solo
circa un terzo di terrore dio nazionale
è uno scenario credo abbastanza
drammatico che cosa si può fare
si possono sicuramente fare interventi
di policy non è scritto nel libro della
storia che le cose debbano andare così
ma qual è un ostacolo forte un ostacolo
forte e la cultura espressa da posizioni
come questa questa è la posizione di
martin feldstein che è stato consigliere
di reagan che ha un'enorme diffusione
anche nel nostro paese
questa affermazione di sostanza dice il
problema è la povertà non è la
disuguaglianza che vuol dire che la
classe media
diventerà un problema soltanto quando
sarà diventata povera c'è qualcuno che
la pensa diversamente e sostiene che
questo non accadrà mai perché the middle
class è troppo grande per fallire noi ci
fidiamo non ci fidiamo di questo atto di
ottimismo in ogni caso conclude ray non
un bel punto interrogativo
grazie
[Applauso]